A movie character can become a timeless fan
favourite with just a single memorable scene
or line of dialogue.
But even the most well-known movie heroes
and villains still have some secrets to tell,
proving they're one of a kind - for better
or worse.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 Secret Hidden Details
Behind Popular Movie Characters.
Hook
The modern reimagining of Peter Pan made a
ton of changes to the classic story, but the
movie's version of Captain Hook was unforgettable.
Dustin Hoffman can take the credit for showing
the evil pirate to be seriously insecure,
leaning on his trusty first mate Smee for
support.
More support than fans realized, it turns
out.
When Hoffman and Bob Hoskins were trying to
figure out how to approach the Smee/Hook dynamic,
it finally clicked: the two weren't friends,
but lovers.
It wasn't what the director intended, and
is never explicitly explored in the movie,
but for the actors on screen, they were playing
partners in more ways than one.
Mad Max: Fury Road
You may not know his name, but everyone who
saw Mad Max: Fury Road knows Coma The Doof
Warrior, the pale-skinned guitar player leading
Immortan Joe's war boys into battle.
His origin isn't explained in the movie, but
director George Miller and Australian guitarist
iOTA came up with one anyway.
Apparently, the child music prodigy had to
watch his mother killed by bandits in front
of him.
Joe found him sometime after, and recruited
him into his army.
Coma wears his mother's face over his own,
which means a lack of real close ups is actually
a good thing for the squeamish.
The Joker
In the decades since Batman's arch enemy first
appeared, his origin story has remained a
mystery, with most agreeing that a villain
like The Joker is scarier without one - even
the more colourful version seen on the 1960s
TV show.
Alan Moore's "Killing Joke" made the popular
case that The Joker was born from "one bad
day."
That idea didn't fly when Batman star Adam
West was asked his thoughts on Joker, claiming
nobody can go that crazy without prolonged
abuse.
In his mind, The Joker was abducted as a child
and kept prisoner for years by an abusive
clown, resulting in the grinning killer fans
know and love.
Jerry Robinson, who co-created Joker was on
hand to agree, simply stating that "that would
do it."
If that's the origin for the campy version,
who KNOWS what caused the darker takes on
the clown prince of crime.
Snow White
She may have been Disney's very first princess,
but the voice of Snow White was harder to
pin down than even her famous costume or songs.
Walt Disney and his casting department heard
over 150 young women with none fitting the
bill.
When a casting director was complaining about
the lack of talented young singers to their
music teacher consultant, fate took over.
The teacher's 20 year old daughter Adriana
overheard the complaints, and started singing
in the background to grab some attention.
It worked, too: once Walt Disney heard her
voice, he cast her as Snow White immediately,
guaranteeing that the movie would revolutionize
Hollywood, and make Disney a household name.
James Bond
For entire generations, the wealth of actors
who've played 007 can't change the fact that
Sean Connery did it first - and did it best.
He's remembered for embodying the sexy charm
of the ultimate alpha male, but Connery didn't
quite live up to that standard off screen.
Aside from the rumors that Connery would "tighten
up" his pecs by holding bags of ice water
to his chest before shirtless scenes, the
thick hair on the actor's chest was sold short
by his scalp.
Connery wore a hairpiece on every single one
of his Bond adventures.
We wonder what Bond would have to say about
the studio's first choice to play him?
The Notebook
Since movies began, there's been a place for
sappy romances.
But The Notebook changed Hollywood love stories
forever, pairing the beautiful Rachel McAdams
and Ryan Gosling as two young lovers, skyrocketing
them to super stardom virtually overnight.
Gosling's role as the lovesick Noah made him
an A-list heart throb, but that wasn't the
director's plan.
According to Gosling, he got the part because
he wasn't a leading man, with the director
saying "You're not handsome, you're not cool,
you're just a regular guy who looks a bit
nuts."
We'll let his fans decide how accurate that
turned out to be.
Saving Private Ryan
Director Steven Spielberg knew that the main
Squad of American soldiers in his World War
II epic needed to be convincing, so he sent
the core cast on a week-long boot camp so
intense, almost all of them wanted to quit
before it was over.
The resulting camaraderie showed it was worth
it, but the boot camp served another purpose:
since Matt Damon didn't have to endure the
training, he was as much an outsider on set
as Private Ryan was in the movie.
Ryan still won over the soldiers and audiences,
but the resentment and insecurity on screen
isn't faked, proving tough love can help create
a more sympathetic young soldier.
Back to the Future
Every fan of time travelling teens knows Biff
Tannen, the high school bully who made life
a nightmare for both George McFly and his
son Marty - in multiple timelines.
But did you know the meathead is actually
taking a very real shot at a Hollywood executive?
It started when director Robert Zemeckis and
writer Bob Gale pitched their first film,
I Wanna Hold Your Hand, to Universal executive
Ned Tanen.
The meeting ended with Tanen screaming at
the pair, accusing them of antisemitism, among
other things.
They got the last laugh though, burying a
stand-in Tannen in manure - multiple times.
Fast & Furious
The entire cast of the Fast & Furious series
has become more famous than anyone could have
guessed, but it didn't happen by accident.
When Michelle Rodriguez was first brought
in to bring Letty to life, she had a problem
with her character's journey - specifically,
that Letty would wind up cheating on Dom with
Brian, the undercover cop.
It was just another way Fast & Furious took
cues from the original Point Break, but Rodriguez
refused, offering to quit if the script wasn't
changed.
But she made a good argument, and the love
affair between her and Toretto wound up as
the backbone of the entire movie franchise.
The Dark Knight
There's no denying what Christopher Nolan's
Batman did for comic book movies everywhere,
but there's one part of Christian Bale's take
on the Dark Knight that draws more criticism
and mockery than any other: the Batvoice.
But Bale's Bruce Wayne isn't really the problem,
since his raspy growl actually seemed an inspired
choice in the first movie, Batman Begins.
But in The Dark Knight, Nolan decided to add
some new effects in post-production to make
the rasp a bit... stranger.
Fans still have every right to mock the insane
Batvoice, but few realize that it wasn't the
starring actor to blame for it.
Those are the awesome secret details behind
some of our favorite movie characters, but
which ones do you think we missed?
Name them in the comments, and don't forget
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one!